So I'm sitting here
with Lauren Castellano,
who's a production
strategist here at Udacity.
She deals a lot with producing
material for our online courses.
She's going to talk to us a little
bit about creating online content.
So thank you so much for
talking to us today Lauren.
>> You're so welcome.
>> So
the first thing I wanted to ask is,
any of students who are familiar with
other platforms may have noticed it.
The production values at
Udacity tend to be very high,
and I don't mean that
solely as a compliment.
Because when you produce
content more on budget,
it's easier to make it available
to a large number of people, and
when you have a high cost associated
with it, it kind of creates a barrier.
So why do we invest so
much into our course production process?
>> So I really look at it
as a long-term investment.
You wouldn't put this much time and
money in a class we're just
going to release to 50 people.
So we're seeing, we want to see this
through, and see students learn from
these classes for years,
with edits to update them, but.
Another thing we've really done is
we're investing the student experience,
not just the course itself.
So yes we could give our highly
qualified instructors a camera and
they can just stand in front
of a blank screen and talk,
but we add a lot to it so that the
students can have the best experience.
So it takes a lot to have
all the different quizzes or
just making it a little bit fun.
When we were talking about material
design and filming with Porsches,
you just add some stuff and
it makes a better student experience.
So it's investing in your
student not just the course.
>> Yeah, it sounds like we're
kind of taking that opportunity,
knowing that instead of just this being
presented to 75 students a semester,
it's going to be presented to
thousands or tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of students
to really increase what we do.
And do maybe we'd like to always do, but
we just don't have the resources
to do it, initially.
And that's one of the things we tell our
professors when we're getting started
with our courses is, this is
the opportunity to do what you've
always dreamed of doing
with this course.
Because you probably can't get the
funding to do it when you're teaching it
to 75 students once a year, but
if you're teaching it to 300 students
three times a year,
you can do a lot more.
So in your position you deal with
a lot of people who have never taught
online before.
Many of them are experienced teachers
in person who are just making
the transition to the Internet.
Others are subject matter experts
who have no teaching experience and
they're just experts in some
domain that we're interesting in.
So, let me ask you first when you're
dealing with a teacher professor who has
an abundance of in-person teaching
experience but has never taught online.
What are some of the unique issues you
wrestle with in trying to transition
them to teaching in this
online environment?
>> There a lot of things, one thing that
you really have to address early on is
the nerves that come
with teaching online.
That a lot of people don't
really want to talk about.
But when you teach in a classroom to
30 people, if you kind of mess up
explaining something, oh well,
shoot your students an email.
But when you're recording that and
broadcasting that to potentially 100,000
students, it's a little more terrifying.
And another thing I see really often is,
with the more experienced instructors,
is they start to teach for their peers.
And, not for their students.
Because they have to look good for
their peers and
people that they're going
to see at conferences.
And, that can get a little bit
dangerous from a students perspective.
But one of, I think, the best things
that come out of that is that
the teachers, the professors will
validate their material even more
than they would just standing
in front of 35 people,
because they know it's
going to be out there forever.
They know their peers are going to be
reviewing this too, and they take more
pride in that, and, I think, so those
nerves can kind of play in our favor,
but also against us, when we start to
lose the student experience in that.
So when they try to teach too high
level, and it's like, don't do that.
>> So when we're dealing with that issue
and we really want to make professors
remember the student experience and not
just focus on teaching for their peers.
What are some of the things that
they can do in this environment that
they can't do in the regular classroom,
that we need to make them aware of?
>> That's a great topic.
Because when you get to teach online,
the sky's the limit.
You have so many options.
And it's really important that you
think about, when developing a class,
that you think about,
what are the good teaching tools or
examples that I've used in class.
Strictly because I'm
constrained within four walls,
and how can we expand on that?
The sky is the limit when
you are teaching online.
You can do a million different things,
and use really cool teaching examples
that you could never use in a classroom.
One of my favorite examples is when
I got to teach with sea lions and
I was teaching about classical and
operate conditioning.
We got to go to a laboratory,
see some sea lions and
teach the students that way.
And they could see how sea lions
were learning husbandry skills.
It was really awesome.
And I could never bring a sea
lion into a university classroom.
I've asked, they won't let me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
you can really stretch the box that way.
And it's really important for
instructors who have taught the same
class for every semester for
the last ten years,
and they use the same syllabus,
to kind of just shred that.
I would like to tell our instructors
don't just think outside of the box,
there is no box.
The world is your oyster when
it comes to teaching online,
so really just getting that creativity
out of them, when they're so
accustomed to doing the same thing over
and over again could be challenging.
But it's endlessly important for
a student experience.
>> Yeah, I imagine that with many of our
professors who have been teaching for so
long they're very good at
the way they teach right now.
But I've encountered some at least
that I think have forgotten that
certain constraints that they have,
and it started as constraints,
that now they're just kind of
part of the fabric of the course.
It's something like I have the topics
broken up in a certain way,
well you only have the topics broken up
like that because you've been forced to
teach hour and a half lectures all,
for the past 20 years.
Now you can have a 15 minute lecture
followed by an hour long one.
So you have a lot of flexibility there.
But what about for
those incoming instructors who have
no teaching experience whatsoever.
They're subject matter experts at Google
or Facebook or something and, they don't
know what it's like to teach at all,
but they're experts in their field.
How do we help them get
accustomed to this?
>> So, one thing that's great about
the subject matter experts is
they've never started within that box.
So, they are really good with
the creativity and just expanding on
different ideas in giving the practical
application of what they're teaching.
One of the things that we
have to remind them to do is
anticipate student's questions.
And they don't have experience
with students in a classroom,
raising their hand saying, wait,
I don't understand that point.
So as course developers,
we try to highlight different areas.
And you see expert blind spot
a lot with subject matter experts.
When you don't as much
with professors because
they're used to students saying no,
that doesn't make sense.
So teaching them about expert blind
spot and saying okay, you're using
jargon there that your intro students
are not going to understand.
And they're in environments where
they don't have to think about that
kind of stuff, which is great for them.
But it's important for
the students that they don't do
that anymore when they're teaching.
>> So, Lauren is an expert at producing
online content and as a result,
she may be using jargon that some
of you aren't familiar with.
[LAUGH] So, Lauren, can you tell our
students what expert blind spot is?
>> Shame on me.
Well so expert blind spot is when
you have an expert in a field and
they use jargon or explain the topic and
forget that some people might not know
the foundation that the expert has.
So you have to take yourself back a few
steps and figure out what it is that
you just assume people know and
what it is people actually do know.
So we try to have people lose
their expert blind spot,
by not having an assumption of
the knowledge a student has coming in.
We actually need to go in, and
explore what their base knowledge is.
>> I have a very fond memories of
my freshman calculus class being
taught by a Nobel Prize
nominated physicist.
>> Fun.
>> Who had no idea what it was like to
not know how to do a derivative.
And so yeah, I think that's-
>> Yeah.
>> A very important
thing to wrestle with.
And because we deal with so many
subject matter experts here at Udacity,
it's even more pertinent, because
they have no teaching experience.
All they know is their field.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think you're right,
it's also a great chance to have that
kind of blank slate to work with
someone who hasn't developed any bad
habits or hasn't really incorporate
those constraints of the classroom
into their outlook on teaching.
>> Exactly.
>> So in this classroom we might have
many people who produce online content
for this class or might go into
teaching online in the future.
In fact, that's one of the project ideas
for this class is to actually film
a mini-course for
some topic you're interested in.
So for those who might want to do
that for this class or in the future,
what advice would you give them on
getting started with online teaching?
>> I would say to really
reflect on your past teachers.
Pick and choose what things that they
would do that you really, really liked,
and really dissect that.
Were they good teachers because of
the context they were teaching in, so
were they great in a classroom, or
do you think what they were doing would
translate really well to online,
and how can you expand on that?
Just shred every syllabus you've ever
seen and really start from scratch.
Do the whole,
think way outside of the box.
That there just is no more box,
and be creative.
Start out with the most
outlandish ideas, and
then reel it in based on
your production constraints.
That way, you know, you'll at
least have a fun class at the end.
Another thing is to be
a really honest consumer.
You know, how long is it and when you're
watching this video until you want to
speed me up or skip to the next video?
And then try to reflect on that and
make a class that you would
actually want to watch.
Sometimes sitting through
a 20 minute screen cast or
head shot is not how you want to do it.
Most students would just fast forward or
be done with it.
So reflect on that and think about
the content you're making and
make sure that you're
picking the right medium.
Some things are just better
if people read them.
If you could create a PDF that they
should reflect on then come back to
video or discussion forum.
I don't know if you'll have that or
not, but look at your content and
then pick the best medium to teach that,
teach that content by.
So is it video?
Is it a screen cast of something?
Is it a reading node?
Which we call a reading node, but
I guess in your case you'd probably be
creating a PDF, but something like that.
I think the most important thing
is being the honest student.
Think about things from
a student's perspective.
>> Yeah, I know that we've probably
given you some examples of some
courses out there that we
consider to be high quality.
We have not given you any examples of
courses that we don't consider to be
high quality because we don't
want that attached to us, but
feel free to ask your fellow
classmates on the forums for
examples of online courses
they've taken that were not good.
And they might recommend some
courses from other platforms.
They might recommend
some Udacity courses.
They might recommend some
Georgia Tech courses.
But that will give you something
to actually learn from, and
see not only what to do but
what not to do.
So, thank you so much Lauren for
talking to us today.
>> You're so welcome, yeah.
>> And thank y'all for watching.